for the first time in a long time we
have another creative collaborator in
the office
you need to figure out how to work
together
we've decided this year to start making
videos for all platforms we're going to
be putting out videos on youtube and
original videos on facebook as well now
hey what's up how's it going man pretty
good how are you danny right yeah
nick good to see you welcome danny made
it big on vine
he's super funny he's super talented he
really understands that like super
compressed short form comedy even
shorter form than youtube most of what
i'm going to be doing is creating
original videos for facebook doing some
strategy for twitter and instagram as
well then also just taking videos that
we've made on the corridor and sam and
eco channels and cutting them down and
putting them on facebook too really to
just like broaden the corridor brand to
facebook and instagram and twitter
because those have been kind of lacking
we have to figure out how to share ideas
how to brainstorm you know it's it's a
whole process and so that's the real
challenge here can we can we all get
along we wanted to have a little being
on uh when to actually shoot these
things and hopefully what we need to
produce up okay after this i'll try to
like whip up some kind of concept for
this yeah i know usually people say
think big but for this content we're
thinking small if the script is one page
you shoot for one hour we're talking
about micro content so basically this
first week our expectations on working
with this stuff with danny is to come
out with just a bunch of great tiny
micro videos they're so minimal that it
doesn't make sense to go online and like
make a production document because
literally this is all we need in like
four days when this production's over
i'm just gonna erase it so one we came
up with is this kylo ren workout plan
one based on the meme going around from
the last jedi where kylo ren is
shirtless and he's got this like really
wide body yeah that that's not a bad
idea actually the one that we're
shooting this week it's a video about
the nintendo switch the switch has those
detachable controllers and so you can
basically play in like any configuration
you want like you can be sitting like
this and holding the controllers
you film a dialogue scene where like no
one's actually like looking at each
other it's like
like what
i don't know that could be the whole bit
is it's this it's this dialogue scene
between two people and it's just sort of
like these medium shots and two people
talking and the short just like yeah
and then it zooms out and we're both
looking at switches and like
we're both playing in the pockets the
biggest unknown for me is like how is my
brand of like comedy and filmmaking and
like my style going to fit into the
corridor brand and like can i find this
like happy medium between the stuff that
corridor makes and their brand which is
already really well established and then
my stuff which i've sort of established
for myself how can i bring that and
apply it to corridor is that a good
enough payoff and how do you know that
they're i mean you see the switches but
how do you know that they have the
controllers you need the third person to
come the third person who's not doing it
it would have to at least be like 30
seconds yeah yeah i was thinking 30
seconds but like whatever
hey man
hey is it the sponsor time i am excited
about today's sponsor because it is
audible and it's been a while who's
making the noise
it's been a little while since we've
done an audible sponsorship which means
i get to recommend a cool book that i've
listened to recently and i think you're
gonna like this one it's a science
fiction book a cross between
independence day and hitchhiker's guide
to the galaxy let me tell you about it
the book is called columbus day no it's
not a history lesson it's actually more
of a metaphor for how an alien race with
far superior technology comes to earth
with the intention of just destroying
the indigenous population aka humanity
so what happens is that a bunch of space
hamsters show up and start destroying
our infrastructure until a bunch of
space lizards show up to fight them off
and that's great because we're like you
saved us humanity is forever in your
debt and so we team up with these space
lizards to go fight the space hamsters
on another planet but the problem is
that we might be fighting on the wrong
side of the war
so what i really liked about this book
is the universe that it sets up there's
a whole lot of alien species and they're
all warm with each other and there's a
bit of like a cast system involved as
well got the big races at the top with
all the technology humanities all the
way down here at the bottom of the totem
pole what are we gonna do about all of
this
this is a military sci-fi book however
there is a lot of light-hearted humor in
it which i really enjoyed and i found
myself being really invested in the plot
as our hero goes to another planet and
learns how to fight alien species
however it's not until about halfway
through the book that it suddenly
becomes amazing
now you can now you can pan it now you
can pan it alright you know how this
part works audible provides you with a
free audio book along with a 30-day
trial membership to audible so you can
get that by going to audible.com
sam and nico or you can literally text
message the word saminiko to 500 500.
that's then that's a new thing honestly
this service is great it has an
unmatched selection of audiobooks i use
it all the time in fact it was a
lifesaver for my trip up to a seattle
and back driving also the alexa
functionality is pretty fun there go the
good old days when we humans only got
killed by each other alexa stop
ha you're welcome so again go to
audible.com sandmannico to get your free
audiobook i recommend this one but you
can do any book there's literally
thousands of books
what are you waiting for go get it now
oh yeah and text it to 500 500. say my
nico here's the text
i'm not going to say that f word don't
want to get demonetized too hunter
street's great it's cheap it's a great
location it sucks shooting here because
everything's dirty spent too many years
of my life here i'm over the dirt i'm
over it let's just shoot a quick thing
like oh you mean you want to shoot
something like in this like dirty
hole oh like what kind of location is it
it's like yeah it's like like dirt it's
like a dirt hole
talk to your friend about his christmas
wait who's you
what do you feel like my alex cause i
went to seattle oh yeah you're more of
an alex i'm more of a band
definitely we came up with this idea
where two people are having a
conversation they're sort of talking to
each other but they're really playing
switches which are behind each other and
they're playing with their hands in
their pockets so you can't really tell
that they're actually playing the switch
the entire time yeah i mean
yeah well the thing is is i've been
having some communication issues lately
uh
yeah sorry that was a little bit
hey guys if you want to level up your
own screenshot abilities i recommend
pulling it into a computer and adding
this depth of field effect because no
one else is going to be doing this i was
like did i forget to bring it to
move it
i know a lot of you guys have probably
gotten a nintendo switch for christmas
and the one game you probably got for
that is mario odyssey that are breath of
the wild both are great games but for
this video i want to talk about mario
odyssey because it has this really
really cool gaming feature within it
that's called photo mode and this is
something that you might recognize from
lots of games these days if you hit down
it'll actually pause the game and allow
you to move the camera around like you
know zoom in zoom out line up photos
standard procedure if you hit left and
right you can cycle through various
filters like this pencil drawing
it's cool i guess but there is one
filter here in particular that stood out
to me because it is a depth mat so a
depth mat is an image that basically
says where objects in the scene are in
relation to the camera and it's denoted
by how dark the pixels are essentially
the darker the pixel the closer to the
camera the object is and this is used in
visual effects all the time to kind of
denote how far away something is from
the camera aka depth the time we use
this effect most intensely was smallest
empire we released that a few years ago
in that we applied this fake depth of
field effect kind of like this miniature
effect you're essentially just blurring
out things that are too far away from
the camera or too close to the camera
and you can actually choose a focal
point that feature got me thinking about
how i can utilize that to make my
screenshots have a really cool depth of
field effect applied to it so i started
taking a bunch of screenshots along with
the depth matte screenshots as well as
you can see i've got various screenshots
with a depth mat accompanying it and you
can kind of see very clearly how as you
get further away from the camera it just
gets brighter and brighter the idea here
is to create a screenshot as if you took
it on a nice dslr camera that's the goal
so let's try to see how that works so
i'm using after effects to do this
effect i'm happy with the screenshot and
as you can see if i turn on the depth
mat it overlays perfectly on top of that
image how will you actually do anything
with this information there's an effect
in after effects called camera lens blur
and it actually will read this depth mat
to apply blur at varying levels across
the image if you go down to blur map
right here you can actually select your
depth map i'll increase the blur just to
kind of see where the focus point is
whoa okay that's that is disturbing this
is a really extreme example i'm going to
dial this back you can actually see how
mario is in focus whereas everything
right behind mario is out of focus and
so yeah it's it's a really really easy
effect to do but here's the other thing
i prefer using a different effect called
freeschluft
it's the plugin we used on smallest
empire so instead of camera lens blur
i'm going to apply a free loop fl
the reason why i'm using freeschlift is
i feel it deals with the edges a little
bit better so what's really cool about
free sleep is you can actually pick the
points of focus you want so i can as you
can see right here i'm going to select
mario's face boom he's in focus and it
also handles the edges around his hat a
little bit better than camera lens blur
and then i'm going to select the
building in the background back here now
that's in focus you're not going to be
able to do this using just your phone or
just uploading it directly from your
switch it's probably far more effort
than it's worth that's basically it if
you have any questions about it hit me
up on twitter or on the reddit
i'd be more than happy to you know give
you some pointers or help troubleshoot
any problems you might have if you want
to elevate your screenshotting abilities
in mario it's you know it's good to be
back it's good to be talking to you guys
again it's good to be talking to you
nick
don't hit me
and if you liked that video click that
subscribe button maybe even hit that
bell to get notifications be part of the
notification squad i see you guys in the
comments we're trying to hit a million
subscribers by may 17th norwegian
independence day this is the only
important day corridor's birthday i
guess there's that too anyway we're
trying to hit that we got another
hundred thousand subscribers to go so
consider subscribing i'd appreciate to
see you around thank you
moment of truth man all right here's the
video red carpet world premiere
that's cool it's a lot of fun man how
about you you spend time with your
girlfriend's family right it all blew up
on christmas morning now why damn it
no
no
no no no no
[Music]
cool
hey if you guys want to see this video
head on over to our quarter digital
facebook page link in the description
below
give the page a like share the video
even or do that yeah do both actually if
you guys like danny and want to stick
around make sure you like the video and
share it
if you don't just don't say anything if
you don't you don't have to comment it's
fine
just
yeah that's a good video though thank
you
[Music]
you